- [Instructor] Alright,
now let's get some practice
estimating, subtracting decimals.
So, over here it says 12.93 minus 6.1
is approximately equal to what?
This squiggly-looking equal sign
you can view as roughly equal
to or approximately equal to.
So, pause this video and see
if you can figure it out.
And, you shouldn't
really need paper for it.
The whole point of estimation
is to be able to do it quickly
and get close to the answer.
You don't have to get the exact answer.
Well, let's think about it.
The way my brain would do it is 12.93--
Let's just round each of them
to the nearest whole number.
So, this is going to
be approximately 12.93
if I round to the nearest one
or to the nearest whole number,
I'm gonna round up to 13.
And 6.1, if I round to
the nearest whole number,
I'm gonna round down to six.
So, I could say this
is roughly 13 minus six
which is equal to seven,
and that is indeed one
of the choices there.
And, when you're doing estimation,
you might have gotten a
slightly different result,
but I'm guessing that the way that
this question was set up,
that if you do any type
of reasonable estimate,
that you're going to have a number
that is closer to seven than
any of the other choices.
And to be clear, sometimes you
could do this in your head.
For example, 12.93 minus 6.1,
you could say 12 minus
six is going to be six.
And then you have 93 hundredths minus,
you could do this as 10 hundredths.
So, it's gonna be 93
hundredths minus 10 hundredths
is 83 hundredths,
plus .83.
So, just like that,
you could do something like this and say,
alright, the answer here
is gonna be 6.83 exactly.
And that, once again, is
approximately equal to seven.
But, the whole point of this exercise
is to get comfortable estimating things
because a lot of times in life
you don't need the exact answer.
You just need a rough answer,
just to know the ball park
of what you're talking about.
Let's do another example.
So here, we are asked
what is 56.75 minus 46.9
approximately equal to?
Once again, pause this video
and try to work it out.
Well, here I'm gonna do the same thing.
I'm just gonna round each
to the nearest whole number
and then subtract.
And, I'm gonna write it out,
but you could do this in your head.
So 56.75 rounded to the
nearest whole number is 57
round up,
minus 46.9, I would also round up to 47.
And, in our head this is
pretty straightforward.
This is going to be equal to ten.
And, that is indeed is one of the choices.
And, normally in life
when you're estimating,
you don't have choices like this.
I guess this is just the easiest way for--
This if off of the Khan Academy exercises.
So, for someone to be able to grade it
because estimations can be different,
so you have to pick
the one that's at least
closest to what you came
up as your estimate.
Now, let's do one more example.
And, I will write in purple.
Alright.
So, pause the video again.
See if you can figure this out.
Alright, so 49.7, I'm
gonna round up to 50,
4.16 I'm gonna round down to four.
So, that's going to be
approximately equal to 30--
Oh sorry, that's gonna be
approximately equal to 46.
And, we do indeed see
46 as one of the choices
right over there.
So, hopefully you feel comfortable.
There's nothing fancy going on here.
The whole point of this
is to just get comfortable
doing things like this in
your head and estimating
and rounding numbers so you
can get a ball park sense
of what this difference is going to be.